[Music]
this week we've got school of deaf
survival sauce and Quarantine brick it's
cool upset what do you think it is I
want a home mixtape Joe you got a
mixtape of you blowing back and inspired
I got all kinds of want to film you
listening to his miss tape and see how
long you last
[Laughter]
I bought a long time with all you got a
what I bought it but it's for it's a
guitar like electronic sound like it zap
zap in Raja light you place the room
yeah a little bit that was the real
chord I felt like it was the easiest
port on earth you guys can't see them
are [ __ ] filthy Wow you guys don't
appreciate it
[Music]
I've known this [ __ ] for like 10 years
we're over it okay
I love it any someone appreciate I love
it
give me more send me the sound family
[Laughter]
are yours and everything that was legit
that was not funny I know it's not funny
because it feels good it's true it's
really good hunters anyway so for our
first story uh which is school as theft
do you can you guys guess if you can
look at my school they teach you how to
steal so it's not that literal oh if the
play on words school of like a school of
rock for criminals so you got school of
rock an actor from School of Rock got
caught stealing guitars oh that's trench
oh I know buddy some way he's an adult
now was it one of the kids yeah else now
I know the story I don't know anybody in
this but Jack Black I remember anyone
from that me neither and the little
Asian girl that was like really good oh
yeah does that tall asian guy how's that
oh he's so agent you mean the keyboard
please leave guitarists in School of
Rock for the Oh Zack attack or something
yeah so he was caught stealing guitars
oh damn you all know he just looks like
the same person with a beard school rock
come out cuz I feel like there's a lot
longer than I realized I know it was
like she doesn't boarded and was it
really tell about your eighties epiphany
that you had yesterday five years ago so
yesterday we're just sitting there and I
had a PIFAN E and I'm like it's 2019
next year is gonna be 2020 and in 2020
but it's my boy
in 2020 the 80s are now forty years away
dude
I kid you not whoa my son went to school
and they had 90s day yeah and I realized
that if they would have had the version
of 90 day when I would a kid was a kid
it would've been sixties day and that's
how far the 90s were yeah that's crazy
getting old is really weird I was just
at playlist live in Florida oh yeah yeah
and you know I'm like one of the only 30
year old people there it's so [ __ ]
funny to see like as an older person now
how young people view you it's just like
a lightweight teacher
you can you feel that now Oh
but then it's also perfect cuz I
remember having the hots front teachers
and now it's also perfect yes so now
[ __ ] my wife who looks like what a
teacher was to me back then oh so I get
to [ __ ] put hands on her all day and
it's and I'm an adult man now and it's
awesome it's like you're still the same
little boy and now this adult body
that's exactly how much you
I felt oldest [ __ ] last night when I was
looking at tick tock that's the first
thing where I felt like you know what
these kids nowadays I don't get it
get it off my phone I can what is tick
tock tick tock is like music with like
snapchat it's yes and maybe like a
little bit of mine and a little bit of
thriller or Thrillist something like
that thriller
I feel so old I don't know you got me a
little snaps well you guys really
explained it now I know what tick tock
it's hard it's like it instant know it's
like vine that's 15 min hour 15 seconds
yeah with a little bit of the the
filters and stuff from like Thrillist
thriller I used to do the music like it
played music for you and you lip synced
along to it ever was before music oh it
was before musically I just see people
doing sped up music and like dance moves
and stuff yeah I tried music we want
sound like musically stars that are like
rich and getting real record labels I
have a friend who's one she she was like
one of the top people or musically do
you have to sing or do you do just lip
sync to it you just lip sync yeah but
some people are original artists on
there and they put their own song in
there and then they lip-sync to their
own but it's not cool mostly kids
consume music lee.carter art yes it's
like the littlest kids yeah like my
niece does it she was like uncle and I
was like that kid yeah get a baby with
your tickle you know what's been
consistent Instagram is what our kids
love that chipmunk [ __ ] chipmunk [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah that's been consistent even
when we first started YouTube Fred was
[ __ ] hot he was this better
yeah my kids love that high-energy
sped-up [ __ ] and we like the chipmunks
it's a good point
oh yeah I still like the [ __ ]
shipment that was a [ __ ] I like that one
that harmonizing they rise to it like it
when they do the Christmas song that's
the jump in amazing it is it is that's
like distinctly the chipmunks though
yeah yeah and then how they go harmony
are they perfectly placed Eve and I said
the Christmas song only
it's a Christmas don't delay one so Joey
here the guy from school Iraq he stole
an $800 guitar a black fender worth $700
and yo he's that broke Gibson lip Paul
Goldtop worth 1904 $2,000 and he also
stole an amplifier how did he how is he
carrying all these guitars yeah he did
it like one at a time and like you know
and he'd be like oh can I check that one
out and then he'll just be playing and
just walk out of the store away while
he's walking his foot and then he went
back and got other ones different
stories all I see yeah this was you
would pawn him off
yeah he would go to Kwanzaa is he on
drugs that's he blamed it on that hmm he
blames it on drugs you want it more
crack you see you used to want child I
just wanted to be a child actor I don't
want to be a child actor I do he's cute
he's very cute if you're charging but
it's I think what happens is the type of
environment and parents [ __ ] up the kid
dude and it's also because my kids were
child actors a little bit my younger son
was there are Nickelodeon and they were
on grass and stuff and I realized what
it is it's when you're on set but you
guys have been on set production people
don't they're not there to raise your
kids they're there to get a good
performance out of the talent yeah so
when the talent is five years old that
good performance is fruit snacks or they
were like to try to buy my kid a puppy
they're like we'll just bring it to set
so he could pet it I was like are you
insane oh yeah
they just want you to be happy so you
can deliver so one day my youngest son
and I was just like family I got to do
with these kids when I go home and if
they're entitled on set all day then
they're gonna be entitled on the rest
live cuz if your son kids man virgania
and say that can't afford this [ __ ]
exactly so one day my son was like I
want a banana before I start I want a
banana he was like for like he wasn't
even betta DVDs just was like man he's
noticing because kids realized when
people would do stuff for them so he's
like I want a banana every well we don't
have any and the PA was like our I'll go
to the store and get him a banana and I
was like no you won't come home and
there's no bananas you eat an apple or
you don't eat so don't know bananas and
I'll take him off this set will quit
this show before you be a freaking jerk
your dad yeah I was like fin but that's
what it is like production doesn't care
about raising your kids cuz they don't
go home with them their job anything
with actors - right like they they
become entitled because just keep them
happy don't [ __ ] up the vibes cuz the
whole production relies on them having a
good vibe now make that actor six and
what makes you happy candy ice cream
McDonald's whatever these people don't
care and if you get that stuff all the
time and then the parents start getting
used to it cuz we're on the set a little
rascals these little this carrot oh like
mama mama jersey stuff they're worse
with the kids sometimes like none of
your kids were on little rats
yeah myself plant buckwheat in a remake
of little rascal straight-to-dvd
let's look straight into the bench
straight-to-dvd target the kids like it
yeah yeah but some of the parents were
like well our trailer is supposed to be
bigger and and and where's my special
lunch and I ordered this and that and it
was our first time being on set so we
were just happy with with peanut butter
we were like crafty would it you can eat
this stuff at any time but you don't
have to ask for words like a free buffet
yeah this is great
but literally get shoot away with a we
had like steaks and stuff and they'd
have like pizza best over a team like
yeah I love that dichotomy watching
extras get treated like they get [ __ ]
like like a hose turned on me so did you
pour your kids out of acting cuz you
know what I ended up like slowly pulling
them down because I realized like you
have to miss a lot of school to do it so
in the schools they're missing school
then kids are looking at them weird and
it's really hard to raise saying
children if they are in the environment
all the time
you gonna mean like it takes a lot more
than than we really had time to do think
of the money though you could I could I
personally was like I told them this if
you really want to do it we will support
you but it takes a lot and if you really
want to do it you want to do it later in
life we'll support you then as well but
like it was really important that our
kids were really developed and like
saying because Hollywood would chew you
up and spit you out and now you're stuck
with that mentality and now you gotta go
work at Target and you feel like you're
you're too good for that dude I honestly
think that I got these two these parents
lovely people we did a movie called
internet-famous
and my character in the movie he has a
YouTube channel called that's one scared
baby and he scares the [ __ ] out of his
baby and he just does baby pranks all
day long and so we had to get hot we had
to actually cast a baby role and the
parents like by the end of production I
was scaring that baby so [ __ ] much
that that baby at the baby
[Music]
exactly therapy four years old smoking a
cigarette like Steve ruin my whole
infant I know
no they're afraid they're they're like
they have dreams and to them the
boogeyman is like Steve green with a
[ __ ] bed no but okay so by the end of
the movie the parents like we're at the
premiere and some Ricky we're like wow I
can't believe you put your kid in this
movie you know like a lot of them we're
talking around and yeah and the parents
like yeah I don't think we would never
do this again like I don't think I don't
think we're gonna be doing acting and
[ __ ] I'm like dang just this one
experience just crash them how lovely
people mad no we're moving on to our
next story so there was this guy who
survived five days in the snow chap car
by eating packets of Taco Bell's fire
sauce Oh what yep so like the snow and
closed the doors where he couldn't open
it
yeah and like the windows maybe it all
fell on you should
commercials for them so his SUV with it
along with this doggie - what the doggie
you can get yeah so he tried to walk to
safety and like this is too far away it
was too cold it was too far so they
ended up having to resort to just being
there I wonder how the car got trapped
this is an organ so he got it was just
like deep snow well so was the driving
and it got stuck yeah oh because of that
and Taco Bell heard about this and so
they gigas would they do they gave him a
care package and just the sauce just
glasses just saw the napkins you should
open it they should have sauce and then
he digs deeper and it's just sauce yeah
but they also give me your supply of
Taco Bell that's cool how much did he
have on hand in these cars get five I
heard one a day yeah they reported three
three yeah damn this Jeremy and the
doggy and so they're saying like luckily
you know they were found alive by
someone on the snow damn after day three
that dog was gonna be dead I love my job
but after Dave all five after Dave
[ __ ] five I'm like damn dude it's
either me or you are used today and
they're like it looks like a turkey
didn't freeze to death because he would
turn on the car periodically to try to
like keep themselves warm so that means
he didn't sleep probably not dude the
state of internet celebrity right now I
can't wait to see this kid at playlist
live next year
and he's like hi I'm to talk about sauce
guy the guy who survived this card talk
about no I'm surprised I could he
couldn't use this phone have you been in
the mountains that look like some
I never have service or sex ever
that's that picture I thought you
could've got out barge it just you
yeah there's trees so like we're
supposed to do if you like if you are
stuck in snow or mud or sand I think as
a lack of knowledge you can break
branches off and you lay tracks under
the tire so that provides grip so I
think you could have got out by
something you know probably costing you
out right now he's like [ __ ] you
don't think I tried all this [ __ ] you
think I wanted to be here I don't you
know branches on the floor would wait he
could climb out the window right is
erosion well I'm saying like you can get
the car out of the snow if you laid
tracks on the floor with the branches
well you couldn't get his [ __ ] trunk
out of mine without help so I did not I
was in the middle of the lake he's in
the middle of a blizzard bro where's he
gonna go where I see the trees in the
background the cars probably the warmest
place around e2i nobody could get out of
there
he could have gone entered no new
information she's like now you're
crumbling I'm not yeah you are that's
why you gotta use chains did they say
which flavor they were did they say if
they were fire on fire I bet you he
found those packets too like in his car
like under the seat or something yeah
he's been saving them there's just still
so many questions I have about the story
that they don't they probably should
impede outside in the cold and then they
get caught back in the car whatever you
probably peed out the window but I'm
like did the dog survived all through
the packets too like what's going on in
this story I don't know they never ask
those questions man the real question
yeah moving on to our last story a man
has been criminally charged with
breaking a measles quarantine by leaving
his home to go to the gym oh come on
dude that's so selfish I heard about
this that's [ __ ]
oh it's all about the pump though he's a
carrier
can you can spread it yeah so they
quarantine him they said like you cannot
leave your home until you are no longer
deemed
contagious he's like yeah I couldn't pay
it he wants the pump I'm too strong for
this [ __ ] you wanna be swole so what do
they do they tackle the [ __ ] out I was
about 24-hour no saw cop and off-duty
sheriff's deputy saw him because he knew
about the quarantine order and he saw
him at the squat rack gym with his gym
bags and I'm getting in the car his his
wife drove him to the gym like he was
hiding in the car so he knew whose wife
book and hope yeah and the wife also got
in trouble he had them are these people
I don't know anymore it's just the whole
thing that guy's an [ __ ] no people
could beat measles they don't like the
equipment down now I got measles because
I'm trying to get big it's too risky
yeah I'm not gonna the gym either
because I don't know measles yeah
exactly I haven't been in weeks before I
even knew about this my body was like
you know what it might be a measles
outbreak don't tell me where this
happened you it happened in LA they must
think needles is like having a cold I
know right what is measles not even
ortho its deadly dude what is this like
a skin disease it's like a [ __ ]
ancient disease what's like it's like
old I didn't know people's stupid
chicken pox rubella it does they have it
boils yeah so it's like spats what is it
they're saying that the symptoms don't
appear until 10 to 14 days after
exposure they include cough runny nose
inflamed eye sore throat fever and a red
blotchy skin rash I thought we were all
supposed to get shots for this yeah they
do say that it's preventable with
vaccines but then now there's all these
auntie backs so was he an auntie back
sir he are you a pro back cert if yeah
oh I'm pro site I'm Pro back sir me time
anti backs are you really but I am a
plat I am a fighter through though no
are big times the truth I think that if
you got in a plane and went up I think
that it it is round looking but not
round my friends a flat earther and he's
dead seriously oh really oh yeah I
interviewed him on my podcast and he's
real
smart - yeah cuz another one of my first
was a flat earther but he had no hair
what's his biggest argument the plane is
a huge one it's if the earth is flat I
mean if the earth is around and your
plane goes straight you would have to
keep tilting the plane down to
compensate for the car so true explain
that you basically go straight and you'd
never have to tilt down you know he flew
he went on up on a regular plane and he
took a leveler and like had it on the
well he was in a Netflix documentary as
well never sat dr8 about flat earth and
he was he was one of people who spoke on
it but planes never tilt it all do when
they go down they don't go like this
they just they descend whilst it while
staying level basically if you fly for
straight forward you should go into
outer space bro because if you think
about the earth I'm not agreeing with
him right I don't know how to tell you
don't know how to explain it
well that's very convenient was like all
bodies of water don't curve like if you
feel the bathtub with water it takes the
form of a bathtub but if the earth is
flat how is it curving around and what's
gravity for for him so he doesn't
believe in gravity he said it's all
density so if you put a ball in the
inner this guy so his thing is it's just
density so the reason when I jump up and
come down it's not because of gravity is
because I'm I'm more heavier than the
earth and the plane goes up because the
jet engine is fighting against the
density of the what about the
experiments that they do sorry we really
knew no no but what about the
experiments where they drop like a rock
and like a penny and it
it's another density density but here's
the thing where it's it gets weird
in this video I really have a great
answer for I was like what about the end
of the earth eventually you get to the
end of it's flat right so his answer was
there's pirates like the cost me the
government has people on boats it
basically will point guns at you and
tell you to turn around and if you
actually get to the game there's like
ice walls that are really tall and you
yes basic that's exactly what I said
yeah that's what his answer was if it's
flat this is what I don't understand
right if we go like to Asia how come
we're not cut off you know mean like if
it's not so his his answer is so you
know The Truman Show yeah right it's
just a big though he's like the earth
isn't here like this is the earth and it
goes around like this so we go from
America to Asia here and there so we're
not really going around the globe we're
just going around the government it's a
government conspiracy oh they know
something the whole like it's like a
loominatee on a global scale was his
answer for that
and they if they control you with little
things like that did imagine the other
things they can control you because I
was like what does it matter if it's
flatter like what what what could you
gain from that and he didn't have like a
clearing money always money but money
money makes sense to me but he was like
it's it's control there were Sun
Watchers and it was a whole thing oh no
you can monetize pictures of like around
earth that flew over Antarctica though
they do that all the time
so I'm like what nobody's saying that
everything's on just the plane though
like you know no but I get okay so
you're reading from the wall if the
North Pole is the center right and then
it's like shaped like a disc like this
yeah Antarctica's at the end right if
that's the case then you you shouldn't
be able to go over an article because
that's the wall you would bump into the
rest of it but people fly over
Antarctica all the time well his
argument is that no one actually really
does that they've just been told they do
that and the air pirates
yeah well the the overall global
supremacy group is the one that allows
you to fly the the routes that the
planes here's the thing I think that the
moon is [ __ ] he says that too I
think it's not even real dude it's not
even [ __ ] real it's true that's what
you think though he doesn't really we
went to the moon like it's a whole it's
it's all thing what the moon itself is
not real
[Music]